there are a lot of people who are 45 to
60 years old who just are complaining
about Millennials and they're not
actually asking how they are getting
back in the mix by becoming a beginner
again and are being held accountable for
parenting and creating the Millennials
[Music]
[Music]
everybody it's gary vaynerchuck and i
have a really special guest here an
entrepreneur that I've known for a very
long time and I got an email I get a lot
of emails I got an email either from him
or his crew and they're like chips got
some stuff to talk about I'm like yes so
here we are thank you on MLK Day we're
filming and recording this chip Conley's
in the building chip why don't you tell
everybody who's listening a little bit
about yourself and then very frankly
some of the things that you want to talk
about and then we'll riff yeah so great
to be here and congratulations on the
digs here thanks pretty nice um staying
at the equinox hotel right nearby which
is very very nice getting at getting a
massage tonight so yeah I started the
second-largest boutique hotel company in
the US when I was 26 I called you a lot
of Eve based in San Francisco all 52 of
the hotels were all in California sold
it and then seven years the first one
star cuz I know this audience when they
hear that hyperbole everyone's like how
yes I was two years out of Stanford
Business School in fact I was hanging
out with my friend Seth Godin yesterday
here in New York and who I went to
business school with so I started the
first one by buying a pay-by-the-hour
motel I'm not because I was frequently
been fun because it was cheap and how do
you have any capital I raised about 1.1
million dollars so I was 26 I had gone
to Stanford Business School gone
Stanford undergrad had a lot of friends
who had money good money I was not from
a money family and I here was this was
1986 86 87 so give me I don't you know
it's funny that's a little bit like I
don't know time I don't know yes enough
before my time that I don't have a good
enough read on how ridiculously hard or
see easy even going to Stanford you know
when I hear 8687 and I hear 1.1 yeah
like I'm like oh that's a real
accomplish you know now I don't know
well I'll say this
listen raising capital is its own game
in itself but you know today you don't
have to be that remarkable to actually
be able to raise a million dollars for
start-up idea because of what's happened
the last decade that's true in Knight
pinkness for me in 1986-87 in the
Stanford world like was that incredibly
difficult was that two families that had
so much money that it like well give me
a little little context to make it
practical is about 20 investors all
putting about 50 K each in so it was it
was like a syndication that's what used
to called it and if people think it was
crazy to go I was 26 and a hotel
experience again now the 22 year olds
getting a million bucks seems common
then it seems to me like an enigma it
was wacky and it was an or was things
happening because it was San Francisco
Cisco was this was a semo's not what it
is today then um long story short is it
would be people were betting on me not
on the business plan and not on the real
estate because it was a broken-down
motel in the Tenderloin of San Francisco
so and it became so I raised the money
to be three and a half years to to sort
of get it to a place where it was
clearly a success story it became the
rock and roll Hood Hotel in San
Francisco so everybody from David Bowie
to Linda Ronstadt were staying there as
this funky motel and how did you get the
first yet the first get like the first
percent is a great story I you got
because that became the Domino terms of
the investors know terms of the guests
yes it was all about the tour manager
everybody thought it was all about going
out and marketing to the travel agents
know is actually the person who made the
decision was the guy who's about five
years older than the rest of the band I
wanted to make sure they didn't do an
overdose or the group he wouldn't like
hijack them yes and so we gave that we
did a deal where we said we have a
massage treatment room you can get a
free massage if you bring us ten room
nights and so the tour managers started
talking to each other and next thing I
knew all the tour managers and the bus
drivers the bus drivers like just
because we had free bus parking - so at
the end of the day you got to determine
like what do you have that's your
benefit and we had a massage studio and
a parking lot and the
my manager bought it and next thing I
knew we were we basically for 33 years
now that hotel it's called the Phoenix
funky Motel in the Tenderloin
and then you know crazy what are you
there every day I was there every day in
the early days yeah I mean I was
learning the business I didn't know
anything about it
of course I didn't go to Cornell hotel
school or anything right now so why
don't you want to do it I loved I first
of all I had a lot of people staying on
my couch so you know market research was
like why are you all staying in my house
why don't you stay in a hotel and they
kept saying the hotels in San Francisco
are either really expensive or really
boring who are these people friends who
are coming to visit San Francisco so I
should grow up I grew up in LA I grew up
in Long Beach not snoop dogg's high
school LBC famous I love it Long Beach
Poly high school number one in high
school little slightly different high
school when you and Scoob were there or
same yes it was about ten years younger
than me but he's stayed in my hotels
which you would need to know after snoop
stays in your hotel room but so yeah
when I was back there no I was either
they called me curious white boy another
basketball like you you and I so last
time I think I said yeah we were playing
we were summit and see apply a top deck
playing basketball court basketball
while he was in his sandals if surprised
like I'm nobody I had that company for
twenty four years sold it's now a Hyatt
brand and long story short is I seven
years ago was asked by the three
founders of Airbnb to come help them
grow their company into a global
hospitality brand so I've spent seven
years as Brian Chesky x' mentor and I
was the head of global hospitality and
strategy for the company for four years
full time and then to the last three
years just been like a strategic adviser
to them that's cool yeah so that the
thing that and part of his I'm here is
because while I was they there you know
they called me a curious white boy when
I was in high school they called me the
modern elder at Airbnb and I did not
like that
but I was twice the age of the average
employee at at maybe I started when I
was 52 I'm 59 now produce listening my
great run in kind of the Silicon Valley
investment world definitely
was kind of like oh five two like oh oh
six two like 2010 and what's interesting
about hearing this story is that chip
absolutely like was in those circles
with me and was just like like there was
a bunch was probably like 40 to a
hundred fifty people that weren't
hardcore tech had come from different
backgrounds but we're kind of like in
the mix one way or the other and so it
makes it's really fun to hear that
that's where you ended up and how it
makes so much [ __ ] sense because the
value prop on context and reps that you
were able to bring that exact company is
like the most logical [ __ ] I've ever
heard well it was so funny because when
I joined first well for the first five
months we didn't tell anybody had joined
so we didn't tell the press we wanted to
see how Brian and I got along because
that was did you meet Brian original
Brian just called me you just called me
he said you know consensus Brian what
did I say about Brian Brian you know a
lot of people think it's the hubris that
makes you a great seat CEO it's actually
the humility and in case of Brian
Brian's case he's had the humility to
say I don't know a bunch of stuff so I'm
gonna go out and and when I come in
hospitality I'm gonna go talk to this
guy who's in San Francisco who's created
a boutique hotel companies an
entrepreneur and in the mix with our
community he's in the only mattered
that's true and it always does but I
remembered very vividly oh my god all
the people who looked at me like what
the hell you're doing when it finally
was announced five months later it's
like why would you my my well that was
your old mind brother than though you
had no clue what air B&B what yeah it
was so anyway long story short is it's
been led me to becoming this modern
elder and what the house of modern older
so in the traditional elder of the past
was all about reverence you revered your
elders but a modern elders about
relevance and so you better be as
curious as you are wise so I 852 I was
joining a tech company for the first
time I didn't understand the lingo but I
had to learn and so what I had to do was
be humble I had to be open to like
saying I don't know what you [ __ ]
mean by saying you're gonna ship a
feature explain that to me and I and so
I was the person who could come in and
make the bridges and create the bridges
to the travel industry and I was Brian's
mentor and helping him to look at
leadership from a CEOs perspective but
the problem in our society today and I
think you've talked a little bit about
this in the past is we're gonna live
longer power is moving younger and the
world is changing faster and there's a
collection of people in midlife who feel
irrelevant and bewildered and have a ton
to give do but to your point
and I'm sure my team smiled because it's
a word I talk a lot about it's gonna
take humility on both fronts for sure
there are a lot of people who are 45 to
60 years old who just are complaining
about Millennials and they're not
actually asking how they are getting
back in the mix by becoming a beginner
again and are being held accountable for
parenting and creating the Millennials
my fits my favorite dynamic right -
literally I go to these dinners or
whatever and like they're [ __ ] on it
and I'm like you're the parent you're
the one that created this in China you
know because everybody had to have a
[ __ ] trophy here's the thing I've
learned you know I had something to
teach Brian Brian had something to teach
thousand percent and I had a hundred
mentors over my seven years now at
Airbnb and each one of those hundred
mentees I'm sure had 100 met well
interesting I said that I had said I had
100 mentors well I did I'm gonna say a
hundred mentees but mutual mentorship is
the future of learning and development
in hoppity's I am such a [ __ ] buyer
of what you're putting down right now I
I think we're about to go through the
golden era we're going through in a
veiner yeah I hired a new chief creative
officer and I told him one of the things
I want to do in 2020 is hire retired
copywriters literally from the Mad Men
era they'll be there so much to bring to
the table nobody looks at them as a
viable option I like literally can't
wait to hire them a a lot of more so
financially sound on the East Coast here
any way that like they'll be thrilled to
work for minimum wage let alone
something more than that and it'll be
fun yeah and the kids are gonna learn
after it's the tech industry I think the
advertising industry probably has the
highest level of ageism out there
because I think that's right I've such a
foreign or to it now that I'm in and I'm
like there's yes I don't understand how
you're not as creative at 52 as you were
at 39 it's silly it's so there's a lot
of opportunity here and that's
so what that's led to is I wrote this
book called wisdom funny I apologize we
talked about football before I went on I
think a lot about coaching yeah look at
the two coaches that are gonna be in the
Super Bowl
yeah once a vet coach and one finally
and once a young coda well any spins a
super one no and hopefully it's not
finally for you because you're a Niners
fan you don't want him to win this one
but then then you have Shanahan who's a
young buck right and the NFL you've seen
that you've seen a guy go with Carroll
and Belichick and Reed over here who are
the old girl guard and then you've got
this whole McVeigh Shanahan young guard
and I and I really actually believe
there's a lot there now I actually think
you know in politics I think a lot about
the founding fathers of how young they
are and how old a lot of our politicians
are and I think that's great but I think
you need the mix of to in the friction
and I think you're I'm very much buying
what you're putting down and I think
knowing you enough from the outside
world in the serendipitous ways we've
run into each other I'm excited that you
are clearly thinking about being one of
the champions of this conversation
because I think it's a good one well
it's why I wrote this is also gonna
bring a lot of happiness well you'll
have to help a ton of 45 to 70 - you
know what's interesting is people's at
you're 44 ok couple thoughts on 44 44
frankly you're right there at your life
has been different than the average
person but you know the lowest point of
happiness in in cross culture is about
age 47 interesting so what happens is
this new curve of happiness people are
happy and they get less shapes how old
are you
understand I knew you were shaking your
hand on that 47
or a happier and you found it to me in
that ring interesting yeah so it's fast
you've gone so long story short is can't
wait three years away
I got your fine I'll be okay listen a
few how are you gonna live first of all
I think 111 for me what level well I I
would do some math so if you live to 111
you're probably not even out into the
second quarter of your adult life yet
you're preachin people now I'm not even
sure I left the dugout yet so when I
when I recently I was hanging out at my
dad scuba diving in Indonesia and I oh
yeah catch and we were I want those
online sites but through my data in
there and they said little 98 let's go
did the math and this was two years ago
there's a year and a half ago two years
ago and I was 57 at the time and it the
truth is if I do live till 98 and age 57
I was not even at halftime of my adult
life style age 80 so you're probably if
you're lived to 111 you might be going
into the second quarter my relationship
with time and the ability to be hyper
but have a great patience graph yeah
it's something that I beat the drum up
very heavily because it will help people
because so many people are anxious
because they think they have to figure
it out at 30 well they see they see
these people like branches' key and my
seven of them yeah exactly so they keep
reminding them well there's [ __ ] 42
of these this is the why a lot of people
feel entitled or they don't know sure
they feel the sense of prior of like if
he can do it I can do it so I wrote a
book called wisdom at work the making of
a modern elder based upon my Airbnb
experience when did it come out came out
last year came out actually came out the
end of last year so and the end of I'm
sorry head of 2018 and do you feel that
that might you know it's funny I really
want to ask you this question came out
2018 late 2018 yep are you excited
because if you're analyzing that
conversation you're a hair early like in
the macro and that it's starting to
build momentum yes on your own personal
take yes the answer is this probably
came out about six months before the
thing started and I would argue and tell
me what you think that's a conversation
I'm passionate about it's still wildly
not being talked about no no ageism or
even just the subject of age diversity
it's been proven that actually age is
the number one form of diversity on
teams so better than race diversity we
need all kinds of diversity let's start
with that but age is a more
effective form of diversity than race
gender sexual orientation etc for a lot
of reasons primarily because our brain
is different as we're old were versus
younger so that led me to reading
creating something called the modern
Elder Academy so it's the world's first
midlife wisdom school it's been open now
for two years it's in Baja so I get to
live an hour north of Cabo San Lucas on
the Pacific coastline
it's amazing great wine in the Bible yes
exactly the Guadalupe Valley so yeah so
I so we've had 707 alarms average age 53
from 22 countries are you teaching I'm
teaching I just taught last week with a
guy named Paul Hawken famous
environmentalists author and
entrepreneur and yeah so it's it's a
mate it's an amazing you so it's a
social enterprise too so we give
scholarships as well so I give about a
million and a half dollars cause it's
like if for a single it's fifty five
hundred for a week double occupancies
four thousand for a week but that's all
inclusive that includes everything
including a massage massage is the theme
here you know some people look at it as
I can understand it so it's four
thousand two fifty five hundred but
there's scholarships a week for a whole
week three meals a day full-on gourmet
staff the kitchen staff the new one like
some people who can afford it or even if
they can't afford it with scholarships I
see it as a mix between advancement and
vacation it's both yes it is like you
know why I'm stopping and again I think
you guys saw in the setup like literally
if you know anything about me like the
email I saw chips name and I said yes so
I literally had no idea what the [ __ ]
we're talking about I'm so Oblivion to
everything like I didn't realize how
long you're at Airbnb and things that
nature but this is so hitting me so
perfectly I want to stick here for a
minute yeah I think it's really clever
because I think what I really like about
it is is like I don't like vacations
yeah like a limit phrase I like
vacations but like I don't want to scuba
dive or like rock climb but this thing
you just said I'm like oh that'd be cool
and I'm pumped
yeah like I'm in a great place and not
looking for like oh [ __ ] I don't know
like
I'm in a great place and I'm like maybe
I should I'm gonna trick chip into
letting me teach so I'll just tuck it
like I lead with a trick so there we go
like fascinated by this yeah more
importantly I've like not exhausted but
I've done a very good job for my own
self judging my own self over the last
36 months to really pounding a certain
conversation to a certain demo I'm
wildly excited about 55 to 90 yeah like
I really am they're really modern elder
period no no I like it
forget about me yeah I want [ __ ] to
realize their 52 and I deliver another
38 years minimum lien like what the [ __ ]
are you wrapping it up yeah exactly the
[ __ ] are we talking about now it's crazy
it's so crazy so the holes chip are
predicated on when people live to 40 all
the rules yeah
well so so the at age 47 was the the
longevity in the year 1900 it was 77 by
the year 2000 so we added 30 years of
longevity in one century but we also
introduced a whole new concept which is
the midlife crisis in 1965 and now it is
55 years later and we've done very
little to address the midlife crisis so
to speak and so my private and you know
we like at midlife suicide are up 50
percent compared to the year 2000 so
long story short is I said I wanted to
create the world's first midlife wisdom
school because the premise there's
there's a new word in in the academic
world called middle essence so
adolescence we know that adolescent is
yep but that word is only 115 years old
so that prior to the word adolescence
being in the lexicon 115 years ago
people at age 13 when they hit puberty
were an adult and you you got married
and you had kids and you worked in the
mind yep etc and then adolescence became
a clear
noop news rely stage the life sticking
childhood and adulthood so we have
middle essence it's the stage between
adulthood and elder hood elder hood is
different than elderly elder hood is a
relative term at Airbnb I learned the
hard way I was a modern elder because I
was twice the age of the average
employee there so I owned the word and I
had to say okay but it's a modern elder
because there's curious as they are
they are wise so what kind of programs
do we have four people in midlife if
they want to go press the reset button
on their life we don't have them and so
that's the bottom line it's cool there's
a study out of Yale from a woman named
Becca levy that shows that if you
actually help people move from a
negative to neutral perspective on aging
to a positive one you actually add seven
and a half good years to their life I
believe that and that's more time added
than if you actually have them stop
smoking or you have them actually start
working out so it's like a public health
benefit listen nobody's a bigger buyer
of perspective is actual life you find
what you're looking for it's all mindset
I believe in that ship yeah yeah that's
awesome that's really really yeah so
what you want to build like [ __ ]
Harvard no I wouldn't war than anything
I'd like to do I've been lucky enough to
be on the board of the Burning Man
project for Burning Man for about ten
years and I just stepped down I'd like
to do what they did or what the Esalen
Institute did in Big Sur which is be the
first of its kind and then basically
create the category and so whether the
category is transformational festivals
with Burning Man or personal growth
retreat centers with esslyn we will
create the category of midlife wisdom
school yeah I like it a lot I'm a buyer
yeah very cool come on down to Baja
I will sit like I really like I really I
talk a lot about people visiting
retirement homes I took a lot about 50
60 70 I think people are just checking
out when the games still on it's because
especially if you're 55 right now you
grew up in a household where your
grandparents were dying around that age
yeah you know like the like people don't
understand how much advancement has plus
you also had hierarchy I mean back in
the old days you sort of paid your dues
and then you got to 55 you said I'll go
out on the golf course and I won't have
to work hard and then the recession of
ten years ago twelve years ago came
along and you lost your job actually I
think one quarter of the people in the
US aged 50 and older lost their job in
the Great Recession and they didn't find
it again okay they lost it and then they
started working at Walmart so there's a
lot of people who fit this profile and
there's a lot of wisdom because one of
the things that has been proven is that
your emotional intelligence grows with
age you have context experience of
second matters so so that's that very
very into
thing it's great to see you it's great
to see you let me ask you a couple yeah
things you've said you had 750 750 alums
now from give me a anecdotal story let
me tell you a little story about the
diverse social enterprise there was a in
our beta period the first six months we
had a forty five-year-old retire male
retired investment banker who was
wealthy but didn't have purpose right
and we had a 62 year old social worker
african-american social worker female
lots of purpose no money
we didn't set them up to actually learn
from each other
but they went for a walk on the beach
every single day because our campus or 4
acre campus right is right on the beach
and so what we've come to realize is
that wisdom is not taught it's shared
and what you do is you create a cohort
of 18 to 20 people and you guys are you
have enough demand that you guys can be
thoughtful oh yeah in the yeah yeah we
very very part of it it's practical
right we cover of Southwest Airlines
magazine January of last year we're on
the cover of the New York Times business
section so this is a for-profit business
no it's a it's a social enterprise I
don't I don't take it done and over 50
percent of our people are on scholarship
in the first year so so could it be a
for-profit business
absolutely are there some big code you
know global hospitality companies
watching us right now yes probably
because you're not because you're an
entrepreneur do you have hopes for it to
be yeah so here's the thing so i which i
think is awesome he's not allowed to
like be in - no I know I know
no but I mean you know I mean this is
very potential to be a for-profit
business do you personally want it to be
I mean that yes I would like to see
for-profit and social and not profit
both right why not both and more poorly
to your point other people feeding off
the hypothesis to do whatever they want
with it yeah I think part of the reason
these global hotel chains are looking at
this is a couple of things number one is
they look at chip they say okay 33 years
ago one of the first boutique hotel
years seven years ago
join Airbnb whenever he thought he had
no logic what's his next thing and his
next thing seems to be this midlife
wisdom school thing right and you have
leverage of success which is gonna make
them take it more so that and then
there's also states that ever know you
know
let me tell you I I don't know you well
enough fastest but I'll tell you why I
so enjoy being underdog and are not
estimated that right now I'm getting
into a funny part where I have enough
wins and consistent wins and I'm out
there or not then now I feel like oh
when I come up with a new crazy [ __ ] too
many people think it's gonna work
and I'm just kind of joined I'm having
fun I was curious what you thought about
that
well let me tell you you how much
enjoyment did you get out of like your
world thinking it's crazy what they are
being me and them being right how much
do you like what are you now because I
bet you the majority people that know
you and your space think this is now
gonna be a success cuz to w's in a row
gives you that clout there's no doubt
about that but you start talking to
people about their age and they actually
don't want to hear it so there's an
element and I'm not I'm talking about
like the executives at these you know
Mary Alton high you know interesting
you're poking I'm selling it's sort of
like okay yeah I'm freaky the CEOs of
those companies so I know pretty well
are not gonna get all worked up because
they've had their success that's right
but it's that mid-level person you don't
know if they're gonna be able to have
their job a year from now
who sort of says oh I don't even I don't
know what a midlife wisdom school would
be so long story short yes I appreciate
the fact that my pedigree has allowed me
to get to a place where people do keep
an eye on what I'm doing but when you do
something weird and and and create a
midlife wisdom school yeah that sounds a
little weird I feel so [ __ ] right to
me yeah I know
it really does so it's then I understand
why I got the email we're gonna see a
hundred of these in the next ten years
I'm a buyer that's my that's my job is
to go out and be on my mind inspire that
so good for you yeah let me know how I
can help but we'll talk about me coming
to Baja thank you love it where can
everybody check it out if they want to
do some homework or what are they Google
they could go to modern Elder Academy or
modern Elder Academy or or come either
one but they can go to my website chip
Conley comm co n le Y and and the book
is called wisdom at work the making of a
modern elder ship thanks for being on
yeah yeah this is gonna see I'm so glad
you reached out because I think that's
gonna hit this audience guys I hope you
enjoyed that please give us some
feedback on social so I can get the
qualitative data on like the enjoyment
or your thoughts on it
I think if you're following this you a
know how much I give a [ __ ] about this
so is smarter chipper team to reach out
to me because this is the right audience
and more importantly I'm also wildly
available are skew younger and have
parents and loved ones that are probably
not even [ __ ] thinking about this so
make sure they listen to this podcast I
think if we impact one of your parents
to get happy that's an ROI positive
event
you